OFFICIALLY THE GOVERNOR-ELECT.
BUCKLE UP IN TIME FOR OUR
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
>> THE CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER IS GROWING MORE SERIOUS
EVERY DAY.
IN ARIZONA OVER 650 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE CROSSING THE
BORDER IN THE LAST 48 HOURS.
ACCORDING TO OUR OWN WILLIAM
LA JEUNESSE A DOZEN MEMBERS WERE
ARRESTED NEAR SAN DIEGO FOR
CROSSING THE BORDER ILLEGALLY.
ONLY THE FIRST FEW HUNDRED
MIGRANTS HAVE ARRIVED AND WE ARE
EXPECTING A COUPLE THOUSAND OF
THE NEXT FEW DAYS AND MANY MORE
AFTER THAT.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
I SAID I REALLY BELIEVE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN THIS
CARAVAN ARE PROBABLY PEOPLE THAT
OUR POOR AND HAVE GOOD
INTENTIONS, LOOKING FOR A LIFE
FOR THEMSELVES, THEIR FAMILY, A
GOOD JOB AND A BETTER FUTURE.
THERE IS FOR US A MASSIVE
SECURITY RISK.
AMERICANS WILL ALSO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF UNCHECKED AND
UNVENTED MIGRATION INTO OUR
COUNTRY, WE SEE IT EVERY DAY.
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
ARKANSAS ON MONDAY.
AT 29-YEAR-OLD ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
OPENING FIRE ON OFFICERS DURING
A TRAFFIC STOP OUTSIDE OF
FAYETTEVILLE.
THIS IS -- CAN FOOTAGE AND I
WARN YOU THAT THIS VIDEO IS
DISTURBING.
[GUNSHOT SOUNDS]
>> SHOTS FIRED!
I NEED UNITS NOW.
>> Sean: THIS IS WHY THEY TALK
ABOUT BETTING PEOPLE BEFORE THEY
COME INTO THE COUNTRY.
THANKFULLY NO ONE WAS INJURED,
THE PERPETRATOR WAS TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY BUT THAT'S THE VERY
REASON EIGHT SECURE BORDERS A
STRONG SYSTEM OF VALIDATING IS
IMPORTANT.
AND THAT'S IN ONE STATE.
AND THOSE WHO ARE JUST TRYING TO
PROTECT US AND ENFORCE OUR LAWS.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS WHO
LITERALLY TODAY COMPARED I.C.E.
TO THE KKK.
WHILE SPEAKING WITH A NOMINEE TO
LEAD THAT AGENCY.
>> THE CLAN IS WHAT WE CALL
TODAY A DOMESTIC TERRORIST
GROUP.
>> WHY WOULD WE CALL THEM THE
DOMESTIC TERRORIST GROUP >> WHAT
WAS THE MOTIVATION FOR THE USE
OF FEAR AND FORCE?
>> IT'S BASED ON RACE AND
ETHNICITY.
>> THE PERCEPTION OF MANY COME
ABOUT HOW THE POWER AND
DISCRETION AT I.C.E. IS BEING
USED TO ENFORCE THE LAWS, AND DO
YOU SEE ANY PARALLELS?
>> I DO NOT SEE ANY PARALLELS
BETWEEN OFFICERS AND AGENTS.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT AGENTS?
>> ARE YOU AWARE THAT THERE IS A
PERCEPTION?
AND, WHAT YOU JUST SAW WAS
BEYOND DESPICABLE.
TO BE THAT PATRONIZING, FRANKLY
IDIOTIC AND UTTERLY
DISRESPECTFUL, THEY PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE I GUESS EVERY
SINGLE SOLITARY DAY, WHICH IS
SHAMEFUL.
HOW MANY ARE INJURED OR KILLED
PERFORMING DAILY WORK?
THIS IS THE MOST RADICAL CROP IN
OF DEMOCRATS TO EVER COME TO
WASHINGTON.
SANCTUARY CITIES AND STATES, AND
WITHOUT A DOUBT, THEY ARE SAYING
THEY WANT TO ABOLISH ICE.
THE VERY ORGANIZATION
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENFORCING OUR
SYSTEM OF IMMIGRATION LAWS.
THEY DON'T CARE HOW MUCH IT
COSTS, WHAT DANGER IT POSES TO
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY WANT WIDE OPEN BORDERS.
TONIGHT, S MIGHT HAVE ONE LESS
CHALLENGER IN THE 2020
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY.
YESTERDAY FAME SEEKING
ANTI-TRUMP ATTORNEY MICHAEL
AVENATTI WAS ARRESTED ON CHARGES
OF FELONY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
NOW THESE ARE VERY SERIOUS
CHARGES.
BUT UNLIKE HIM, AND MANY OTHERS,
THERE WERE SO WILLING TO RUSH TO
JUDGMENT AND NEVER AFFORDED
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH DUE PROCESS,
THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE, WE
ON THIS SHOW ARE CONSISTENT,
EVERY AMERICAN DESERVES DUE
PROCESS.
AND EVERY AMERICAN DESERVES THAT
PRESUMPTION, HE DESERVES IT, YOU
DESERVE IT, EVERYBODY DESERVES
IT.
GUESS WHAT, JUDGE CAVANAUGH
DESERVED IT AND DIDN'T GET IT.
AND HE FIT THE PROFILE OF THE
LOAN BOMBER BECAUSE HE LIVED
WITH HIS MOTHER.
I DIDN'T KNOW AT THE TIME BUT HE
WAS LISTENING TO MY RADIO SHOW
AND I WAS SAYING, THAT MAKES NO
SENSE.
IT TURNED OUT HE WAS A HERO.
AND HE AT LEAST GAVE HIM A FAIR
SHOT AT THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
BY THE WAY, YOU MIGHT REMEMBER
THE DUKE LACROSSE TEAM WHO WAS
FALSELY SMEARED.
ON OUR SHOW, WE DIDN'T RUSH TO
JUDGMENT.
I TOOK THE TIME TO GO AND MEET
WITH SOME OF THE KIDS AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO DO SOME
INVESTIGATIVE WORK.
LET'S NOT FORGET WHAT THE LEFT
DATED IN FERGUSON.
DARREN WILSON WAS NEVER CHARGED
IN HIS CAREER WAS RUINED ANYWAY.
ALL THOSE OFFICERS WERE
WONDERING WHAT HAPPENED WITH
FREDDIE GRAY.
HOW MANY TIMES DID THE PRESIDENT
OF THE TIME, OBAMA, RUSH TO
JUDGMENT.
SO MANY PEOPLE ON THE LEFT, IF
IT FITS THEIR POLITICAL AND
OHMIC AGENDA, IF THEY CAN GET
CHEAP POLITICAL POINTS, THEY
RUSH TO JUDGMENT.
NO PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE EVER
WITH THESE PEOPLE WHEN IT COMES
TO POLITICS.
SO YES, MICHAEL AVENATTI
DESERVES DUE PROCESS AND
DESERVES THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE, EVEN THOUGH IT WASN'T
THAT LONG AGO, HE DID NOT EXTEND
THAT BASIC DECENCY TO JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH.
FRANKLY, JUST THE OPPOSITE.
REMEMBER IT WAS HE THAT PUSHED A
PHONY CLAIM FROM A CLIENT NAMED
JULIE SWETNICK.
REMEMBER THEY CAME OUT WITH THAT
AFFIDAVIT.
AND, SHE WAS ALLEGING THAT WHEN
BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS IN
HIGH SCHOOL HE PARTICIPATED IN
NUMEROUS PARTIES, GANG RATE
PARTIES.
GIRLS ARE SYSTEMATICALLY
DRUGGED, BOYS LINING UP IN THE
HALLWAYS WAITING THEIR TURN TO
GANG RAPE THEIR TEENAGE VICTIMS.
SHE CLAIMS IT HAPPENS MANY TIME
TIMES.
THIS IS SENATE JUDICIARY CAN HE
AND NONE OF THEM WERE EVER
CORROBORATED.
NO EVIDENCE WAS EVER PRESENTED.
SHE LATER BACKTRACKED DURING AN
INTERVIEW.
THAT WAS A CRIMINAL PROBE INTO
HER FALSE STATEMENTS.
IT IS CLEAR, HE WANTED TO DERAIL
KAVANAUGH'S LIFE.
HE DIDN'T GIVE A RIP ABOUT DUE
PROCESS, OR PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
NOW THIS ISSUE HAS COME FULL
CIRCLE FOR HIM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HAVE NEVER STRUCK A WOMAN.
I NEVER WILL STRIKE A WOMAN.
I'VE NEVER SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
ANYONE, NOT IN HIGH SCHOOL, NOT
IN COLLEGE, NOT EVER.
>> I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO A FULL
INVESTIGATION AT WHICH POINT I
AM CONFIDENT THAT I WILL BE
FULLY EXONERATED.
I KNOW THAT ANY KIND OF
INVESTIGATION, SENATE, FBI,
MONTGOMERY COUNTY POLICE,
WHATEVER, WILL CLEAR ME.
>> Sean: IN THIS COUNTRY,
THESE PROTECTIONS, DUE PROCESS,
SHOULD NEVER, EVER BE A PARTISAN
ISSUE.
IT MUST BE APPLIED TO EVERY
AMERICAN EQUALLY.
SADLY, MICHAEL AVENATTI WAS NOT
THE ONLY PERSON ON THE LEFT WITH
NO FORETHOUGHT OR PRINCIPLES
AND, JUST A SHORT TIME AGO, SO
MANY DEMOCRATS AND SO MANY IN
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA WERE
WILLING TO THROW OUT FUNDAMENTAL
BASIC RIGHTS RIGHT OUT THE
WINDOW BECAUSE OF AN UNYIELDING
PARTISAN HATRED FOR JUDGE
CAVANAUGH.
REMEMBER THIS.
>> THIS IS A MONUMENTAL DEFINING
MOMENT THIS WEEK WHEN YOU HAVE
SOMEONE LIKE COFFEE GOING TO
PRISON AND IN THE SAME BREATH
HAVING KAVANAUGH GOING TO THE
HIGHEST COURT IN THE LAND.
THIS IS SICK STUFF.
THE DEVIL'S TRIANGLE AND YOUR
YEARBOOK, FOREVER AND EVER?
>> AND THAT CONGRESS IS NOT
PROTECTING A WOMAN, THEY ARE
PREDICTING A MAN WHO IS PROBABLY
GUILTY.
>> NOT ONLY DO WOMEN LIKE
DR. FORD WHO BRAVELY COME
FORWARD NEED TO BE HEARD BUT
THEY NEED TO BE BELIEVED.
>> LET ME SAY RIGHT AT THE
OUTSET, I BELIEVE THE SURVIVOR
HERE.
>> I DON'T THINK SHE SHOULD BE
BULLIED IN THE SCENARIO, WHERE
AS SHE SAID IT'S A SHAME
HEARING.
>> IT'S DEFINITELY ATTEMPTED
RAPE, I DON'T SEE IT ANY OTHER
WAY.
>> WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE?
THOSE PEOPLE YOU JUST WATCHED
OVER SOMEONE THEY SHOULD
POLITICALLY AGREE WITH, ARE THEY
SO WILLING TO SUSPEND THOSE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS WHEN IT COMES
TO CLAIMS AGAINST HIM?
AND BY JULY OF THIS YEAR WHEN HE
WAS SPEWING ANTI-TRUMP NONSTOP
VITRIOL, GUESS WHAT?
MICHAEL AVENATTI APPEARED ON
CABLE NEWS OVER 200 TIMES.
CONSPIRACY TV AND MSNBC GAVE
MICHAEL AVENATTI $175 MILLION
WORTH OF FREE MEDIA COVERAGE.
WHY DID HE BECOME THE STAR
GUEST?
BECAUSE HE WAS TRASHING
DONALD TRUMP AND MICHAEL COHEN.
NOW TO WHAT DO WE HEAR ABOUT IT,
CRICKETS.
MSNBC ALSO TRIED TO IGNORE AND
PLAYED ON THE STORY.
THAT START CONTRAST OF THE WALL
TO WALL COVERAGE OF THE JULIE
SWETNICK WITH NO EVIDENCE OF
REGULAR GANG RAPES AND DRUGGING
OF TEENAGE GIRLS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE, THIS IS
ABOUT THE RULE OF LAW.
LET'S NOT POLITICIZE CRIMINAL
DIFFERENCES LIKE THIS.
IT'S NOW BECOMING MADNESS.
NOW LET'S TURN TO THE LATEST OUT
OF MUELLER 'PARTISAN WITCH HUNT.
HE WAS SOUNDING OFF AND SAYING
THAT THERE HAS BEEN NO FINDING
OF COLLUSION AND HE ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED HOW MUCH MONEY AND
TIME THE ENDLESS INVESTIGATION
IS COSTING YOU, THE TAXPAYER.
HE ALSO SAID UNIVERSITIES WILL
SOMEDAY STUDY WHAT IS HIGHLY
CONFLICTED AND WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE TO DESTROY PEOPLE.
WHY IS HE PROTECTING CROOKED
HILLARY, COMEY, PAGE, AND PETER
STRZOK?
THEY HAVE SPENT MONTHS DIGGING
INTO EVERYTHING AND ANYONE AND
EVERYONE ASSOCIATED WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHILE IGNORING
WHAT WE NOW KNOW TO BE FACTUAL
AND TRUE.
THAT IS COLLUSION, REAL CRIMES
COMMITTED BY HILLARY CLINTON,
VIOLATING THE ESPIONAGE ACT.
FACT, THE BIGGEST EASIEST,
SLAM-DUNK CASE AS IT RELATES TO
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE THAT WE
HAVE EVER SEEN.
WHY HAVE THERE BEEN NO MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AND HILLARY'S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR?
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE SOURCES
PAID FOR BY HILLARY AND THE DNC
THAT SHE WAS CONTROLLING.
WHY?
IN PART TO INFLUENCE AN
ELECTION.
YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, HOW IS
THAT NOT PART OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION?
WHAT ABOUT DISSEMINATION OF
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE THROUGHOUT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF YOUR
GOVERNMENT?
THOSE RUSSIAN LIES SPREAD OUT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL COME
BEFORE THE 2016 ELECTION TO
PROPAGANDIZE AND INFLUENCE
PEOPLE BEFORE THEY VOTED IN THAT
ELECTION AND USE THEM TO DESTROY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AFTER THE
ELECTION.
WHAT ABOUT THE FRAUD ON A FISA
COURT, FOUR TIMES?
THE BULK OF INFORMATION IN THOSE
FISA WARRANTS USED THE SAME
UNVERIFIED UNCORROBORATED
DOSSIER THAT HE TESTIFIED HE HAD
NO IDEA IT WAS TRUE.
THIS IS ALL BEING IGNORED, WHY?
BECAUSE THE PARTISAN WITCH HUNT
HAS NEVER REALLY BEEN ABOUT
RUSSIA COLLUSION, IT'S BEEN
ABOUT DELEGITIMIZE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, STARTED BY A
GUY WHO SAYS, HE SHOULD LOSE
100000000-0 IN THE ELECTION.
SHOW ME THE MAN AND I WILL FIND
YOU THE CRIME.
AND FINALLY TONIGHT WE DO TURN
INTO GOOD AND BAD NEWS OUT OF
FLORIDA.
FIRST THE GOOD NEWS, THERE WILL
BE NO MORE RECOUNTS IN THE
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION.
SOME ATTEMPTS TO SEAL THE
ELECTION, WE HAVE TO ALWAYS
ASSUME THAT'S A POSSIBILITY.
REPUBLICAN RON DeSANTIS IS NOW
CERTIFIED.
HE WILL BE THE GOVERNOR OF THE
NEXT STATE OF FLORIDA.
AND MY SOURCES TONIGHT SAY
RICK SCOTT HAS PICKED UP A LOT
OF VOTES IN THE RECOUNTS.
IN THE SENATE RACE, THE CHAOS
CONTINUES AFTER A MACHINE
RECOUNT.
RICK SCOTT REMAINS WAY AHEAD
HAVING PICKED UP IN FACT SOME
BOATS, PALM BEACH COUNTY ONCE
AGAIN FAILED TO MEET A STATUTORY
DEADLINE.
SO THE ORIGINAL RESULTS IN THE
COUNTY STAND.
BUT A HAND COUNT OF THOUSANDS OF
CONTESTED OR FAULTY BALLOTS, AND
THAT MEANS THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
FILL IN THE OVAL AND THERE IS A
DOT DOWN THERE AND YOU CAN BET
THAT NELSON'S ATTORNEY WILL SAY,
YOU SEE THAT DOT AT THE BOTTOM?
I BET THEY MEANT TO PUT IT UP
THERE.
DEMOCRATIC ATTORNEYS ARE NOW
PULLING OUT ALL THE STOPS TO TRY
TO MAKE UP GROUND WHICH WILL BE
IMPOSSIBLE.
FOLLOWING THE SUIT, A FLORIDA
JUDGE RULED OUT THROWING OUT
BALLOTS WITH MISMATCHED
SIGNATURES WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THAT MEANS THAT CAN CHANGE 11
DAYS AFTER THE ELECTION.
HE CHANGED FLORIDA STATE LAW
FROM THE BENCH, ALSO EXTENDING
THE DEADLINE FROM SO-CALLED
CONTESTED, WHICH MEANS AND BY
THE WAY, THE SAME JUDGE SAID HIS
WIFE DONATED TO SENATOR BILL